this was the big story of the day so uh
you know we can talk about a lot of news
Donald Trump's being sued but the story
that was sweeping across the internet
from human events British police open
investigation into death of hockey
player Adam Johnson who was killed by a
posing players skate blade uh simple
version of the story a dude got his
throat by a ice hockey skate and then
bled out in the rink died presumably
very very quickly I mean there's video
of it it's horrifying however they the
media kept calling this a freak accident
over and over again and then when the
video came out it looks like this dude
Matt petgrave raises his leg to kick the
other guy and uh there's video of it I
don't want to play the video because
we're not here to play shock content but
it does look like a kick but I I I will
play a little bit I won't show any the
aftermath because it's gruesome but the
first thing I want to do is I want to
show you this Jack pic has this tweet in
the article he says read this to the end
let's read it so this is a post I
believe that was on Reddit and it says
to all the people calling Matt petgrave
a murderer if you seriously think Matt
petgrave murdered Adam Johnson go f
yourself the guy was balling his eyes
out on the ice and in the dressing room
and probably still is right now he's
going to have to live with this for the
rest of his life and the last thing he
needs is people calling him a murderer
the claim that he purposfully kicked his
leg up has some Merit and is a possib
but to say that he meant to seriously
hurt or kill Adam Johnson is pathetic
and disgusting if he did purposefully
put his leg out he did so to get in the
way of or block Adam Johnson from making
progress as the puck carrier not to
slice his neck open his foot clearly
clipped the skate of another player
causing him to lose balance so even if
he did kick his leg out he had very
little control over where his leg was
going now notice they say it has Merit
that he raised his leg but he didn't
intend to do it perhaps the man pet
grave was balling his eyes out because
he did Tred to kick this guy didn't mean
to kill him but did right M so uh like
teenager is joy riding in his car and
speeding and then he crashes into
someone killing him is he crying his
eyes out yes the woman in New York City
the young woman she pushed an old lady
old lady fell over and died did she cry
in court she sure dead MH does that mean
that these people are innocent no so we
have uh we have this
video and uh let me refresh it see if I
can try and I don't want to play too
much but I'm really wants to play it all
uh let's see if we can pull it up and I
don't want to play too much but I want
to just scroll through you can see right
here this is uh Matt pet Graven red
highlighted and this is Adam Johnson and
then you can see him he lifts his leg up
there's no reason for him to raise his
leg like that in fact if he's losing his
balance that's the last thing he's going
to want to do yeah he raises his leg up
right there you can see it and then hits
this guy in the neck but uh not
something we normally talk about but
this is basically the biggest story I
think right now yeah it's like the only
thing anybody's talking about and it's
it's like it's causing a lot of uh uh
contentious debate and uh as someone who
doesn't I played hockey when I was
little so this was like it looks like
murder to me yeah I mean at least like
an intentional manslaughter charge or
something like that because I've played
hockey well well enough to know that
like if I'm in the position he was in
why would I be lifting my out my my in
this case inside leg that high there's
just no there's no reason to maybe Adam
Johnson was leaning down that brought
his neck in connection to like the blade
but still everyone that uses skates
knows that skates are sharp probably has
him sharp too he's playing
professionally or amateur I don't know
it's Pro yeah yeah Pro stuff I mean this
guy knows there's no question people are
pointing out that the the guy who did
the kick has like the most penalties but
I don't know I don't it's it's European
hockey so I don't know anything about it
European hockey uh yeah they get the
penalties for just using the wrong
pronouns it's crazy over that's right
that's right that's Europe straight to
jail straight to jail straight to hockey
jail I don't know about murder but
manslaughter seems reasonable no and
this is what really this is one of the
things that got me like okay we're gonna
human events has the story manslaughter
would be like you're speeding uh no
actually that would still be like a
negligent homicide which I the law is
VAR by state I think Illinois has
negligent homicide and that's like if
you're speeding in your car and you hit
somebody and they die manslaughter is
usually like you're going too fast for
the conditions but you're going the
speed limit you slip SL hit the brakes
spin out of control hit someone and kill
them and then they say you could have
avoided this manslaughter is usually
like someone died as a result of uh of
you being irresponsible yeah right
whereas negligent homicide is like
you're you you you may have been
committing a crime you were speeding but
it's not like the most serious thing in
the world and then in this instance if
dude was intentionally trying to kick
the guy that's Grievous botly harmed
murder yeah if you intend to if like
that that woman in New York she shoved
the old lady mhm yeah she she's going to
prison for 8 years that's it 8 year 8
years that's it she shoved the lady on
purpose I'm sorry a young woman pushed
an old lady on purpose on purpose and
she died and the old lady fell down hit
her head and died and so they're putting
young young wom in prison for 8 years
she should not be going to prison for
eight years for that okay I I didn't see
this one I'm not sure shoving someone is
barely a misdemeanor okay this this
woman in New York who did it oh it
wasn't into the subway she just shoved
her no no she pushed her on the sidewalk
oh okay I thought she was cuz in New
York shoving everyone into the subway
like you go in the subway you get pushed
into the subway I can see I can see your
confusion on the no she pushed the old
lady on the sidewalk the old lady fell
down and died oh okay okay and then she
was like I didn't mean to kill her I
just pushed her and so they gave her
eight years just for that now this dude
kicked the guy in the you know was
trying to kick a guy and he's wearing
ice skates that's murder second degree
murder intending to cause bodily harm
that results in
death I mean I just can't be imagine
being anyone that was on the ice that
day you know what I mean Ian every
report that I saw said that the the guy
died on basically on live TV and that's
tragic the crazy thing
is on the 28th I was in Pittsburgh such
a great City I've heard it is a great
City and uh I was walking with the Alis
and my girlfriend and I left my coat at
the hotel and so uh you know started to
drizzle a little bit wasn't super cold
out but the drizzle a little chilly and
I'm like why I should grab a light
jacket or something I don't actually
have one I have like a Crazy Snowboard
jacket and so there's a bunch of these
stores and they're selling Steelers
merch Pittsburgh Steelers football and
so I'm like I'll just get like a
Steelers thing it'll be like a souvenir
I'll grab it I go into the store
everything is Steelers this Steelers
that and then I walk in the back and
there's this gray like waterproof thin
jacket I'm like I'll grab this and then
as I walk up to the uh uh the counter I
noticed it's a Pittsburgh Penguins
jacket and I was like oh it's a hockey I
was like I don't even know I don't even
know know this is because they're
offseason right now I forget about how
this guy on that day when I was buying
that uh used to play for the this guy
used to play for the Pittsburgh Penguins
he's now playing in uh in the UK what
was he play for the Panthers no no not
the Panthers I'm not sure but he's
playing in the UK used to play on the
Penguins and the guy petgrave is on a
team called the Sheffield Steelers
that's so weird I just thought that was
kind of
weird that a guy who played in the
penguins at the same time is this is
happening I'm buying a penguin's jacket
by accident at a Steelers store a fan
store and the guy who clipped him in the
neck played for the
Steelers I don't know
man what do they think they're gonna do
anything do we think they're gonna do
anything inv yeah I mean oh I mean dude
the UK nah they're going to investigate
him and they're going to let him go and
they're going to arrest his neighbor
that would be very racist yeah yeah
definitely also mean it was listed in
the chat here that he has 71 P penalties
in 11 games so is that a lot I mean 71 P
penalties is quite a bit you're
definitely 71 and 11 games that's like I
don't not a math guy but like it's a lot
it's a lot it's numerous ones per game
so it would be interesting to see this
go to trial I don't know what the charge
would be but you know the defense
obviously can argue in a murder case you
know he it was accident he was on Ice he
didn't mean to whatever else and then
the other people have all these things
to point with already I mean if the if
the media has dug up his penalty record
what else is there I mean did these
people exchange worlds in the locker
room there's all kinds of avenues to
pursue n they're playing on different
teams Lo kind of argument to say this
guy has a history of being aggressive it
it would be interesting I don't think
anyone would be satisfied by the outcome
ultimately yeah it would be it would be
a lot of controvery well hockey is an
aggressive sport so most of them are
yeah pretty aggressive oh yeah he does
play for the Panthers I think yeah the
Nottingham Panthers Nottingham yeah yep
I had no idea the UK did hockey not at
all you're European League yeah no clue
yes a lot of so a lot of people are
saying you know I Mong says should be
manslaughter at
minimum and uh I I can't believe
consequen it man manslaughter is just
like no it's murder if you if you if
like if you attack
someone and they die you murdered them
MH but I guess the argument is because
they're playing sports or something
there's a degree of like Mutual
understanding of physical bodily harm or
whatever yeah but they've got to
understand you you put your leg up
you're wearing a blade on you that's
they do Mur
Pro intent right I mean that's part of
it whereas manslaughter is different
manslaughter is just he died he died
because of your actions I don't know if
they have the law is exactly the same
over there we're talking about it
through the American legal system I
don't know what their legal system is
over there I lived over there but I
never murdered or manslaughter anyone so
I don't know experience you didn't have
to experience it for no I never had to
so you know what's crazy is a lot of
people are bringing up the Clint malaric
is how you pronounce his name malchuk
Mal yeah 1989 there's a video of this
too he's a goalie they crash into him
and then he got his throat slid as well
and then Serge was mentioning it's like
the guy what is the guy the guy runs up
and then like pinches the artery shut or
whatever that's crazy like I don't even
know what you do like I don't even
understand how a doctor could save a
person who's bleeding from their neck
like what do you do to stop that cuz the
blood's got to go to your brain man can
they like pinch it off and the blood
just comes from the other side or
something that's crazy if you can
prevent it from getting out of the body
like if you pinch and close it like if
you can put a b put your thumb over
without actually you stopping all the
blood I suppose keep the flow going I
mean not not that I'm saying that it
would be easy or that it's something
like a task I could accomplish but a
doctor I assumed but not on a hockey
field probably in that in that well they
he did yeah 1989 guy ran up and like
grabbed his neck and pinched the artery
shut and saved his life this one I guess
they didn't know what to do now the
doctors are all affirmative action
doctors hired for there was no doctors
there were none they're they're on a
hockey field and a hockey rink and uh uh
they all just like he's holding it mhm
and it's just spraying and pouring out
well and they probably take that guy
with his thumb in the neck to the
hospital with him they can't pull his
finger out until the last second till
they're ready to do something I believe
the the the guy in the in the video with
malach was like an ex uh ex combat vet
from Vietnam so HEC counted before and
that was he was able he knew what had
what he had to do which is a really
particular thing but man yeah God it's
it's crazy when I see these stories
because people need to realize a single
sentence can save a person's life yeah
true I'm not saying anything could have
done here I really don't know if you
watch the video I mean blood is spraying
out so profusely apparently within 10
seconds he collaps onto the onto the
floor and then he was dead like he lost
way too much blood probably before they
could even pull the cameras away I mean
that's the crazy thing how fast this
happened MH but there's a lot of stories
of people who die and don't need to if
people just knew like a single sentence
mhm you know so in this instance like
what do you do when someone's got a
femoral bleed or Arial bleed or whatever
if someone just said to you the single
sentence of how to make a
tourniquet you could save a person's
life and it's the craziest thing I think
about this like the time span between
someone is injured 30 seconds later
they're dead they lost too much blood
and if you only knew that one sentence
they'd be alive right now that's scary
or if you had first aid equipment on you
you know it's not it's not hard to carry
a blowout kit I I got to turn a like
sitting under the table here man so
that's crazy not going to do any do any
good for you know you're not going to do
any good for uh jugular butt I always
think about these moments man there's a
there's a viral video on YouTube it's
old video of like uh sports injuries
that result in paralysis and it's just
like nightmare fuel yeah but there's one
video where a guy playing basketball
gets frustrated so he bangs his head on
the the bar whatever you call it the bar
that holds
God he's just angry he's like and he
hits his head he goes rigid and falls
over paralyzed forever yeah forever God
yep cuz it like he hit it and it like
hit it it got hit something in his neck
and then his neck went out and then he
fell down and he was like that's it you
can't move there's that crazy video of
that girl trying to do the milk crate
challenge oh god well you they're doing
that kind of she falls down and then
she's like on her her spine it's like no
the one I saw was this girl was at a
bachelorette party and someone pushed
her into a pool I think it was the bride
and then she's paralyzed from falling in
the pool she hit like the edge it was
like an above ground pool and she hit
the edge of it oh and like wow what do
you do from that I can't remember if
she's paralyzed or she died but it was
real really bad like these things that
people do accidentally can have extreme
consequences that's where like with the
with the hockey video I I think he
probably intentionally kicked his leg up
but was it intentional like I'm trying
to kill him you're not you're not going
to kill someone on camera in front of
all those people you know what I mean if
if you're angry at you want to go kill
him going he was going to kick him so
yeah cuz it makes sense the pads you're
wearing hockey getting kicked right here
would not be life ending but I think he
probably was leaning too far forward
he's like it's you're on Ice you know I
don't know what happened he really
leaned too farward and he connected with
the neck and that's man that's how it's
all it's all it's going to happen one
cup that's crazy I feel bad for their
families to be honest like they're
having to watch everyone speculate about
all this both sides true on air like
that's just it must be awful to be going
through this right well I guess I guess
the question of imprisonment and
criminal charges is what are we trying
to do what is the goal did this guy Matt
petgrave intentionally kick Adam Johnson
to kill him I don't think anyone thinks
pet grave was trying to kill the guy no
so so so how is putting him in prison
serving anyone anyone's goals it makes
the PE the family of Adam Johnson feel
better I I I I don't I don't know if
that's the appropriate means of how we
spend money on our taxes I mean great
it's the UK I get it but think about in
the United States like I was talking
about that that woman who pushed the old
lady and I'm like why is she going to
prison for eight years
she pushed an old lady she'll never do
it again she's probably traumatized so
what's the point of of prison it's to
make the family of the old lady feel
better because now she's being punished
for eight years well that's going to
destroy her life I don't think that's
actually fixing any of the problems
perhaps the idea is we'll send a message
they want to make an example so that
everybody knows that if you push an old
lady and she dies you're going to prison
like this lady and then it's just like
you're sacrificing one person for a
message to be sent to everybody else I'm
never a fan of that yeah I think it's a
fear of uh people who exhibit somewhat
violent tend how do we manage that I
mean think about the guy and his name
sing my right now who uh Daniel Penny
had in that choke hold on the subway and
then he had this consistent history of
attacking people on the subway didn't
kill anyone as far as I know but on the
other hand caused very serious bodily
harm broke a you know an elderly woman's
jaw different things like that he had a
consistent pattern of violence and there
were minimal you know interactions with
social workers and the criminal justice
system and ultimately you know he was
once again in a position to be dous and
viol when he Daniel perney he did a
great service that day yeah I mean it's
it's just a question of you know what
what is the point and role of the
criminal justice system and you know you
don't want to you don't want to punish
people too harshly who have learned
their lesson on the other hand we know
that there are people who escalate in
their violence over time currently the
criminal justice system is to uh
manufacture the proper opinions and to
punish people for having the wrong
opinions and and behaving in the wrong
it's a joke CVS they have pictures in in
DC on H Street they have pictures of the
toilet paper roll so you can tell the
people the brand that you want but they
don't have the actual toilet paper out
because it'll be stolen so we're talking
about a criminal justice system like
that thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at
timcast.net see you all next
time